you do have to reinvent yourself I
remember a therapist telling me that
like she's like everyone in show
business specifically said you need to
read senior I'm like that's not what I'm
here for
but I remember her so he sent me to a
therapist about eight years ago and I'm
not gonna say who sent me but he said
you should go see this therapist to deal
with you know I was getting like
backlash and haters and all this stuff
was that I wasn't prepared for what's
going on he goes you should go to this
therapist he works with all comedians he
gets us he speaks our language he he
knows the jargon Montreal me I get into
this therapy session literally the first
thing this guy says to me is sitting
straight across me puts his hands on his
legs he goes Dane Cook your name comes
up a lot
[Music]
and we're back at you up with Nikki
Glaser in studio we got Andrew Colin Xu
Li agar and now Dane again kicking off a
huge tour that you haven't been on tours
of a big tour since 1984 while I know it
was it you know how it is it's like when
you're cultivating new material
sometimes you're on a groove and it
comes together in a year year and a half
you're like I'm good to go
and then those other times in your life
where I've been doing it 29 years you
start going through like an evolution of
really perspective and being
introspective and that all needs to lend
itself to our material so I took a
little more time with it this time
because I felt like I wanted to get it
perfect I'm excited because you were
that's true
you were so famous and so huge so
quickly and then you then you came out
with special special special because you
the demand was you needed to yeah and
you could I mean you you did it but I'm
interested to see what's happened now
with this five-year gap like where what
well it's kinda material for you yeah
you know did you see the you saw the
Shandling documentary yes the thing
about that that like kind of congealed
everything for me is I grew up loving
Carlin and this this is an unbelievable
moment Carlin was doing the hippy dippy
weatherman he had the cardboard cutout
of himself that he brought out on I
guess the Tonight Show and this in this
prolific moment he walked out he was you
know it was lucrative though hippie to
be a weatherman was doing well for him
and everybody knew him is that so he
brought the cardboard cutout out and he
said he was like a lot of people know
this guy he was hilarious we all loved
him but this guy and he dropped his own
picture out of frame he goes is gone I'm
George Carlin all right let's start Wow
and it was this dead silence because
everybody was like what he shut it shut
it down and that was even really before
I got into stand-up comedy full-time and
I thought oh wait you could evolve in
this business you don't
have to stay as one thing or people will
put pigeonhole you and say you're the
guy that rips his shirt off in his pants
saying you pour water on yourself and
that's what you do forever but I already
looked at it is now I can grow up with a
generation of comedy fans I love that
you always kill it on these late night
shows you're one of my favorite late and
I guess and you have been since I
remember when you went on Kimmel right
after the Tom Cruise incident on Oprah
did I say somebody into a bathroom into
a restroom
it was a it was some actress that you
had stationed in because because if you
don't if you don't remember when Tom
Cruise was on Oprah like he went to go
fetch Katie Holmes backstage and made
like a huge thing about it but she had
like a thing on her lip so she didn't
want to be on camera and he's like come
on Katie
so you were on you come out on Kimmel
just so committed to live in love but it
was a magazine that I take my back funny
you have you have to watch Dane Cook
Jimmy Kimmel Tom Cruise just search
those words it is such a you're so
committed to that and it wasn't like
something you would it wasn't the Dane
Cook that we knew at that point which
was I mean you're not an impression like
that wasn't what I expected out of it
was but it was so killer yeah
Kimmel has always been like that place
that they'll let you go and try things
that are out of your lane or whatever it
is the perspective which is great could
have gone so badly oh yeah in your mind
as a comic and as a performer you're
like this has to go somewhere
I'm not just gonna walk out there and
just talk like I want to do so I want to
bring something to the table my comedy
from the beginning I grew up I was a
real introvert you
I had anxiety and panic attacks I was
like I no social skills whatsoever so
anytime I got on stage and the fact that
I even ever stood on a stage when I
couldn't be in front of you know even at
the bus stop waiting to go to school I
was I was panicking it was like torture
so it's like every single opportunity
I'd have to get up there I'd want to
commit everything I had because I loved
it
I hated being off stage I was more
scared in life than I was of how I felt
on stage and I think that's permeated my
entire career of like I got to take full
advantage of this while I can be out
here and feeling this the the bravado
that comes with standing on stage so you
don't take it for granted every time you
go on stage you really feel I've heard
you talk about that and I'm always like
I wish I felt the way about the stage
that Dane Cook feels because I've heard
you talk about this feeling if I just
want to get up there and you cherish
every role reverence for it yeah yeah
it's it's always been glamorous
ever since I saw it when I was a kid
watching Johnny Carson growing up or
Carlin or Pryor it was like I watched
all these amazing comedians and to me it
always felt like wow that's like that's
an occupation where you're always needed
to some extent you know and I think I
wanted to feel that growing up I wanted
to feel like needed I had a I had a
place so once I walked into it I was
like this is what I'm good at I suck at
pretty much everything else in the world
so I just give it all I got well I want
to go back to something you said about
just having extreme anxiety I was the
same way growing up by giving class
presentations I would I would have panic
entiendes a child you'd be like that
would that girl will never be a stand-up
comedian and you were having panic
attacks the bus stop how does one
overcome that if you're listening
someone's listening now being like I
want to do stand-up comedy but it's I'm
too scared what what did you find that
was made you be able to do it I think
that I I was funny at home I would get
home and I felt like that was just I was
safe you know so I could do skits or I
would do you know crank phone calls with
my little Radio Shack plug-in you know I
would make my own jerky boy type calls
and I got a a rush off of getting laughs
if I would play it for a couple of my
friends or my family
and so I think I remember watching
Martin Short on Saturday Night Live when
I was in like 7th or 8th grade and he
was doing at grimly he was doing Jackie
Robinson Jr her dollar jackpot wad yeah
and he just he was so happy he was so
into it and I wanted that really
desperately in my life and so I thought
I'm gonna try an open mic night and how
that happened was kind of a quick story
interesting I was in Cambridge
Massachusetts at kedge rising star
I was watching David Cross was doing his
own cross comedy with an open mic night
so he do sketches and then he bring
potluck performers up you'd sign up and
then you'd show up the next week and if
he called your name you got pulled up on
stage well I was just going to watch
because I was I was terrified and
actually going up there and the third
week the hosts went up and said okay
next on the list and they would randomly
call you goes where's Ernest Glenn there
was like three seconds of nothing and I
knew this guy wasn't there they were
gonna move on to the next name I put my
hand up he goes you're Ernest Klan I
said yeah and he goes all right all the
way from the fifth row Ernest Glenn and
that was my first set ever
and once I did it and felt the way I did
up there I said this is I got a furnace
down I'm Ernest I would Facebook try to
find them from time to time I crush and
you couldn't go by your regular name and
then that guy just sitting somewhere
going I mean no one was more famous than
you in 2008 everything really started
yeah like five six seven eight
everything was kind of a blur even
though I remember all these high-water
marks is what is it what does it look
like to you when you think back on it
like what that must have been I mean
there's no one has that experience I can
only name a couple people who've had
that sky rock there's a lot of columns
in and okay so first of all look at it
mostly as you know this pipe dream came
true so I was I was grateful beyond
because I had a I had a career and it
looked like I'd be able to take
as far as I wanted willing to work I
could take it as far as I wanted to go
so you had all these high watermark
moments of like I'm hosting SNL or and
playing Madison Square Garden and I'm
I'm affiliating myself with I know
rolling so I mean they smashed me like a
year later but that was the next wave of
what happens and I accepted that the
same way I accepted the praise cuz I
knew it was all just a spanking
I think I helped I was like I'm gonna
tear down to I'm ready I'm ready to
devolve and then Evol these great you
cannot sustain the level of Fame and and
and adoration and and just wild energy
around you at that time you could that's
not sustainable so you knew it was gonna
be taken away and the thing that was not
taken away I just knew that it would
crest you own I mean I guess I look at
it I'm always like if I get as famous as
I want to be it will be taken away I
look at it that's we're in it for the
long haul we're gonna you know I do
Jerry Lewis he at 90 years old I'd see
him perform at 90 years old I went
backstage one time he would do a Q&A at
the very end of his show usually lasted
about 35 minutes people would line up
ask questions it was hilarious cuz he
was salty and he was honest and don't
give a he didn't give a right
but it was awesome and so he did not the
35 he did like 15 and I walked backstage
and he was pissed and nobody was near
him and his daughter was like Jerry
wants to see who I was like I don't want
to go near him he looks upset she's like
no he need he wants to talk to a
comedian he needs to talk to you so I
walked up there and he goes I remembered
ninety he goes they lit me early
ninety I said this never ends we are
never gonna be satisfied it's just ever
you know changing and fans are gonna
come and go
do you notice funny as your last thing
with and then they come around it's like
being an Aerosmith fan like I didn't
like that album but now I'm back and
over now what are you doing but now I'm
back I looked at a career is like people
visit and they're gonna come and they're
gonna go but even when you were at the
pinnacle of success you you what does
that feel like you're like I got
everything I could have ever dreamed of
I think that is wild yeah the big upshot
was the level
of what I could share with fans and my
family you know I was very close to my
mom and my dad and it was like
everything that I accomplished and got
to show especially my mom was like a
mind-blowing thing she knew who I really
was from 14 and feeling so broken you
know loading myself at a very young age
she now she's watching me on camera
where I hated who I was
and now she's seeing me you know filming
in front of thousands of people the the
thing that was the hardest was the what
what Fame gets you
super super stardom in Fame what it
really does when you get there is it
invites you and it exposes you to okay
ready welcome now here's everyone that
hates you and your lanes here and you
got to remember that and most people
drift off for years to come and then you
try to get back to your lane the thing
that is the most gratifying is the the
more you have the more you can do for
other people that's the cool thing
whether it's you know going to
children's hospitals or you have so much
more clout to be able to shine lights on
things that you want people to know or
performers or products so that that's
the part that was probably the trickiest
to have to rejigger you know what I'm
gonna do yeah was what was the biggest
I'm just fascinated by Fame I think it's
all something we love doing comedy but
then there is a part of us that just
wants to be loved by everyone and we we
want Fame whatever that is what were
some things that you didn't maybe
foresee when you would become that
famous that became was was going out and
did you become more paranoid to want to
stay in more those kind of things I was
always like a homebody away you know I
built my fan base up you know through
MySpace and early social networking
because I wasn't a go out kind of person
you know I I'm 46 I'd you know if this
makes our lame I never had a drink or
drug in my whole life I didn't do the
half I'm adding here right I'm a cop I
just I loved I don't have the minutiae
of of what it meant to have that
correspondence with fans that really was
kind of a kick for me and also you can
remember I could be comfortable at home
talking to everybody it took away that
anxiety that I felt of offstage how I
deal with people so that sitting in my
underwear with Froot Loops and like
writing thousands of people that was
like my sweet spot it was this is great
yeah you touched on something that I
don't think enough people give you
credit for and that is literally
creating a world where comedians can
promote themselves via social media and
internet you know what you did on
MySpace you know we talked about getting
to the being in the pinnacle of a Fame
for you but the way you got there the
hustle the I'm I respect
hustling people so much manager and and
so many comics
you've helped so many comics by putting
that process together that that template
of going online and hammer and you're
like how does MySpace not send you a
check like I gotta say you're
nailing it because but just not directly
about Dane Cook every single weekend
because I when I do shows and I do meet
and greets afterwards I sometimes don't
want to I'm tired I don't feel like it I
have another show to do people are gonna
get grabby it's gonna upset me but I do
it because I go that's how Dane I know
that's how Dane built his audience they
have a connection with him those people
will if they meet me and have a good
moment they will be my fan for life it's
really true and and I remember you
either reading that you said that or I
just know that about you is that you
would take the time after shows spend
hours meeting longer than the shows I
mean how did you do you still do that I
mean you that's can't be sustained yes
your level now I still do meeting greets
you know with the tour like this it's
hard cuz we're moving the next thing
like that night yeah but if people are
waiting outside or at the bus it's like
I'm gonna be there you know I wanna I
want to make sure I can still you know
hang with whoever wants to meet me it's
it's it's really gratifying you know I
mean it's like people want to you know
29 years later it's like people are as
excited to come to a show and and the
thing that was cool about when I hear it
when people say back to me like this is
what you did that was also at a time
when it just it the old era of comedy at
that point was you didn't do that stuff
I was I was I was barking I was like
doing everything but that was like not
in vogue at the time right and I got a
lot of crap for it but but it just felt
like I was I felt like I was doing
something and then never been done
before business right so I was just I
wasn't following anybody else's lead in
that you were leading the less like if I
up it's okay because nobody knows
what's right and wrong with this but
you're the door just you to do with the
machete just chopping don't follow
me guys and I literally held a machete
how do you know all this they want to
roll their eyes at any kind of
self-promotion you're you're just
supposed to hate yourself and you're
just supposed to that's what a comic is
supposed to be just very just stick to
the course do your set leave and you win
against everything that it wasn't cool
to promote yourself and you didn't care
and listen you yeah now we all do it I
didn't care yeah because it was like oh
wow I get to you know have a great life
I get to have a couple of cool things if
I need it get take care of my family
bought my mom a house when I was 29
years old you know it's like you know a
welfare kid from Arlington Massachusetts
and I get to buy my mom a house
everything that people want to say like
but wasn't it you know wasn't it so
difficult to have a B and C yeah there
were definitely hardships sometimes but
every day I could wake up and go there's
a stage somewhere I can get on tonight
and I know I can get laughs and at the
end of like this whatever this long
career is and I hope I'm 90 complaining
backstage like like my mentor but I look
at it and go to be able to night after
night get on stage and try to figure out
something that connects with a crowd
like that's the challenge that never
gets boring or lessons you know that's
yeah because there's you always have to
write you always have to come up with
new stuff it's it never gets boring
you're so right
tickets for his tour tell it like it is
are on sale now tell it like it is what
are we gonna what are you talking about
on this tour yeah what is that what's
the title come from a lot of the title
is is I wanted to get to a point my
stand-up where I could
use every tool in the Arsenal in terms
of like I still love physicality but I'm
46 I'm not gonna dropkick and you know
whom applaud is on the mic stand or
whatever I was doing before but I still
have that same you know enthusiasm
that's just that's organic you know that
it's like when you see Chris Rock
practicing he's low key and then you see
him on a show and it just you know you
know you get in show mode and you get up
there and it all kind of you know comes
into the the character but I didn't ever
want the character to be somebody who
when I saw you at the meet and greet
felt like it was so different or a
put-on from the show I want to be able
to pretty much keep the demeanor and
walk up and meet you and know I can say
to you I don't I have two minutes dude
come on let's take the picture
and get out of here yeah and it's okay
because you know who I am you know when
I'm about with the routine now and why I
brought Garry Shandling up was I just
love the idea that you could get
introspective and I didn't I had a lot
of observation for many years but I
wanted the introspection so desperately
it's so merry to do that it's scary
taking up a lot of you're digging
up stuff but but with hindsight some of
these things that happen to me that have
been in the moment like so just you know
almost capsizing moments in my life
are hilarious now that I'm sharing them
and telling the stories but why I took a
little longer Nikki was I didn't want to
be maudlin I didn't want to be like hey
this is more one-man show because it's
interest but no no no I want LP M's
laughs per minute the same thing that
you saw on vicious circle or retaliation
but with things that are even more
deeply personal so now that I've got
that we're doing every damn city in the
entire country so excited how long are
you on tour for least until September
and then we're already looking at like
the Phase two of it all and yes I'm so
excited to see your new Act I've always
been a fan and and I haven't seen you
for so long
I'm excited because you did go through
some man yeah I mean and and you
have gotten into some serious stuff in
your past stand-up did you feel like you
were modeling then with with that subtly
are you approaching it different or yeah
I think with with what what you're
speaking on was like when I did isolate
an incident that came after you know my
mom and dad had passed away
a cancer same year nine nine months both
my best friends just like God and then I
went through the stuff with my brother
and this whole financial thing and then
I went through his stuff with CK and it
was like within a three-year period all
these you know pressurized highly
pressurized moments were happening to me
so that was reflected and isolated and
incident and I called it that because I
felt like how I felt in that time in my
life was going to be an isolated
incident
I knew I'd get past it and get to like
whatever I felt before a new normal kind
of thing to quote Oprah I knew and so I
don't look at it as modeling but I just
look at that particular I'm very fond of
that that show Marty Calder directed it
he directed departure from what we had
in it the challenge that year I always
have kind of a new yearly challenge for
myself and wanting to add something to
you know extend the the abilities or
opportunities to tell different kinds of
stories was the whole year I planted my
feet I kept the mic in the mic stand and
never moved for one year January
first to the end of the year I did not
move onstage and so when I did that show
it was to prepare me from being all the
animation to can I tell a whole show
with just my eyes that's crazy there's
so many comics I know that are just the
opposite they're like I'm on stage I'm
just standing in one spot I should move
around because you know people were so
jealous of you and so angry at your
success that you became someone that
people would either pacing the stage
that this thing that we all
loved about you and what made you so
funny that was them being my family guy
and all this kind of stuff cause he's
everywhere I mean you were so
huge dude and and people wanted to make
fun of it even though it was what got
you there and what we all loved so it
makes sense that you were like you know
what I can still do this without all
that and I'll prove it to you and
that's really cool that you what was
your challenge this year I mean every
year you have a new thing not so much
this year but about two and a half after
I did troublemaker troublemaker was the
last special on show time that I did my
time directing amazing because for the
first time ever you know as a comedian
we we finish it and then sometimes other
people are impeding on the process and
maybe an edit is weird or there's always
a little something hinky I wanted to
have something that from start to end I
could create and say I you know this is
entirely how I saw it and wanted it to
be the exact the whole show and so from
that I really I loved that I loved that
feeling of freedom and I liked that I
could I can say no to a bunch of stuff
because of the opportunities comedy has
given me and I can say yes to like one
particular thing that I'm trying to
accomplish so the last three years has
really been about this material and it
just took a little bit longer because
like I said I wanted to I wanted to dig
into the real nitty-gritty of it all I'm
so excited because when you came on the
scene with your Comedy Central Presents
which was just I mean that that's what
wasn't that the first thing that people
just go what does like yeah god me too I
was like oh my god what the this is
working that was crazy
yeah before that it was a lot of years
of different what the fun no that was
what your debut and you had worked so
late you had been working so many years
to have that kind of splash and now I'm
excited to see all the work that you've
again kind of put into this to make a
new kind of splash like it's it's
exciting and I'm I'm just such a fan and
I really am grateful as a comedian for
what you've done for us thanks a lot to
me true dude like I remember getting
into stand-up when I first started
thinking about doing it listening to
harmful if swallowed and I still
remember the stoplight I was at in
Lawrence Kansas when I was laughing out
loud so hard in a way that I had never
laughed out loud that hard and I was
like there's something so special about
this guy I was a huge fan I came to see
you in Vegas when you did the insomniac
to work yeah I flew with my friends
there to go see you know I got I got
picked to be a seat-filler because I had
a regular seat but we were like two hot
girls so they asked us to sit in the
second row and then I got to go to the
VIP party afterwards because we were
seat
and they didn't know I was a comedian I
just started a couple months ago I told
my friend I go you do not tell anyone
I'm doing stand-up that is humiliating
these guys are pros
don't mention it and she drunkenly went
up to you and was like my friend just
started comedy and I go no in you and
you were so so cool you didn't need to
do this at all and I it was the last
thing I wanted was to bother you after
the show and this taping but you go come
here I I have some advice you took me in
the corner and you just honed in on me
and you go here's the deal
don't go to New York or LA it's too soon
for you go to Boston go to Chicago go to
Denver go somewhere else work you just
gave me this TED talk that was like
there was no other involved you
were so nice and it was just I just like
stood there took it all in and like did
that like I followed it and it was great
advice the same kind of advice I give to
people but the fact that you took the
time to do that in that night really
meant something to me and it speaks to
your character she didn't walk away
going boy this guy's not so animated off
stage everyone drank and stayed out too
late and you weren't you were
professionally you did what you needed
to do and I was like oh he's just going
hot like you're an introvert that was it
yeah I mean honestly you know even to
this day you know when I do the meeting
great I love meeting people but it's
that's still the heart the hardest part
you know it's just sitting through the
jokes
Dane Cook is on tour now you gotta go
see him guys the tour is called tell it
like it is you can find all the tour
dates on Dane cocom he's gonna be on
tour til September going everywhere so
wherever you are he's gonna be there
somewhere close by go see him
Dane Cook calm Dane Cook thank you so
much thank you so much
[Music]
you